Hey Jeanie, one more project for you.
It's due Thursday. Is that cool?
Well, Nancy and Ralph might have more time than I do...
...because of this deadline I'm working on.
It will be tough.
Saying no or pushing back on your boss is never easy,...
...but try to avoid rambling in a passive-aggressive way...
...or just blurting out a flat-out no.
Instead, express gratitude for the opportunity,...
...ask your manager what his or her priorities are,...
...and then explain what's already on your plate.
After all, you do want your boss to think of you as the most capable person...
...to come to for any challenging tasks.
That's true.
Thank you for thinking of me for this,...
...but I'm working on a high-priority project that you assigned to me,...
...the Gamma project, and I don't wanna do a rush job on that.
So, can that one be put on the back burner while I work on this new task?
Yeah, you know what, I'll find someone else.
Don't worry about it.
You stay focused.
Thanks.